everybody's successful lays a blueprint
out you laid a blueprint out I saw
myself honestly as a model when I felt
you're gonna have bumps in the road you
want to have things that happen that
make you have a hiccup and I come from a
happy place even in my place was dark
I'm happy Jim Carrey the comedian
doesn't stand a chance against Robin
Williams the comedian I think I'm sexy I
tell my lady all-time babe
I'm sexy as a father you want to teach a
kid certain things well I look back at
my life George you know I'd like to
teach
he's an American actor comedian writer
and producer in 2015
Time magazine named him one of the top
100 most influential people in the world
he currently stars as himself in the
lead role of the real husbands of
Hollywood he's Kevin Hart and here is my
take on his top ten rules for success
rule number one is my personal favorite
and make sure to stick around all the
way to the end for some special bonuses
everybody's successful lays a blueprint
out you laid a blueprint out uh you know
I can go down a list from comedians to
actors to entrepreneurs to self-made
moguls you look at Russell Simmons you
look at jay-z you look at Tyler Perry
you look at puff I mean you're looking
at people to start off with a small
vision and that vision manifested in
something beyond expectation so what I
did was from the people around me my
mentors Eddie Murphy Chris Rock Pryor
who are all on the wall all in walls
yeah also you surround yourself well
somewhere I surround myself with a
constant reminder of who is great
constantly I come down these steps every
day I look at Richard oh he's great I
see Eddie he was great I see Chris Rock
he was great it's a constant reminder
what am I trying to achieve I want to be
great so that motivates me so what
taking separates me is my drive my drive
is other people's success are you
surprised by your success at all I don't
want to say I am because then I think
that means you're doing something for
for a lesser benefit you know I think
you do anything to maximize your
potential in whatever realm you put
yourself in with entertainment there's
so many doors that you can go through I
mean you're literally looking at 15 to
20 doors yeah by going back in your life
would you
ever see yourself in this position
position I saw myself honestly as a
model when I felt my runway
ah no it was weird kids clothes I was
doing the point that I'm making is I saw
myself going in a direction where I
would be able to make people smile and
stand-up comedy is one thing that I knew
that would be able to put me in that
position and stand-up comedy has taken
me into a place that you know is it me
love this life is too short and I feel
like everyone needs to live love and
laugh and understand like you know
you're constantly evolving things a
constant changing thing you're
constantly putting and putting people in
a position where they can get better and
do better we're doing a lot better a lot
better you're gonna have bumps in a row
you're gonna have things that happen
that make you have a hiccup and in
question are we doing better but that's
life that's the course of life but you
know I'm I'm a I'm a positive person I'm
a realistic and positive person so I see
where we are I'm happy where we are and
I know where we can be five or 10 years
ago
they can continue to get better and grow
for me you know what I believe hard work
pays off
you know um when you say it's been a
it's been my year and it's it's my time
you know uh Hollywood has a way of
making everything seem like overnight
success oh my god where'd this guy come
from oh this kid who is he looking at as
a massive star eighteen years in the
business you know he put in 10,000 hour
I put it I put in my time you know I got
I got dues that that have been paid and
paid again and paid one more time after
that I stayed true to my dreams and by
doing that eventually they came true
comedians Gardens stage and they're
hiding who they are you know there's a
lot of comedians come from a dark place
do you let it all out
I come from a heavy place even though my
place was dark I'm happy yeah I'm happy
simply because I have no reason to be
angry ah life is too short to be angry
so the things that I do feel a certain
type of way about it I may get upset
about I let it out I get out on stage
and I allow other people to judge it and
laugh at it and
the reason why you're laughing is
because I'm being honest and I think
when people can relate to that
honesty truth is always a fun yet it is
the funniest I don't care what happens
to you there is a positive and a
negative in anything that happens to you
and you think about it after you're done
being negative I guarantee you'll laugh
and I guarantee I don't care how bad how
severe it is after it's happened when
you really break down what happened a
human condition oh my goodness sometime
sometime well ours in a flower if you
ask any comedian that has a real
understanding and knowledge of stand-up
comedy today people probably say Dave
Chappelle is the best pound-for-pound
okay um and that's including everybody
that's you know this is one of the most
creative guys on the planet when it
comes to breaking down the joke and
making a joke a joke within a joke
within a joke Dave Chappelle doesn't
like nobody else it's a science
true story man Chris Rock watch Dave
Chappelle at the Comedy Cellar
me and Chris Rock went up already you
know man Chris Rock I called Chris and
Chris come down I'm working on some
material I want you to look at it Chris
had hired me too I'm coming down he said
I want you you watching me those punch
each other watch uh I watched Chris
after you watch me we talking about I
says Dave Chappelle comes in randomly -
fell goes up me and Chris watch Dave
Chappelle's swear to god we took out we
took out our material balled it up with
the are we talking about like we were so
pissed off with our level of thinking
yeah like it - James Brown - man thank
you but he's that good now louis c.k on
the other hand it's polished as they
come yeah Louie CK is a bad boy man like
Louie CK we'll take your common premise
and that premise becomes a 10-minute bit
yeah and that bit becomes a a in the arc
within the whole set that he's doing and
when you look at it at the end of the
set what he's what he's bringing on is
you know who he is that's it that's a
great comedian you walk away and you
know that guy's life but not in a way to
where you studied it but in the way to
where you related to it and he made he
painted such a perfect picture that all
you did was just go oh my god I get it I
know that Louie CK is divorced I know
Luiz he cans too
I know that one of his daughters is his
favorite I noted the other little girl
he likes her but she's an [ __ ] I know
I know this because of not only his
material but he says it in a way to
where you can see he's authentic it's
not this is a force comedy and I think
that's the bridge behind those comedians
Robin Williams
oh man doh Oh Jim Carrey of all people
oh we got it we got to be honest you
gotta be on okay all right um Jim Carrey
the comedian doesn't stand a chance
against Robin Williams the comedian uh I
think it's better to break these two
down um for for comedic acting because
Robin Williams as a comedian when you
understand if you really really are
educated a robber was one of the best
impressionist to ever do it and to
really like when I say dive into an
impression Robin winds became the people
that he impersonated like he's he
literally set the arc for so many other
people behind him to start to break it
down and get all the little nuances
because from the from the body posture
to the facial to the mannerisms Robert
Williams pound-for-pound was was the the
best at it when it comes to comedic
acting goddamn it man Jim Carrey you
know if you don't want to give him his
respect that's one of you I will uh Jim
Carrey when it comes to physical comedy
I don't think nobody touches Jim Carrey
when it comes to physical comedy I think
Robin Williams is amazing at adapting to
whatever character he chooses to be in
the film but Jim Carrey sacrifices his
body for it take Jim Carrey throws
himself against a wall he if you look at
if you look at me myself and Irene the
scene where he fought himself and
grabbed his neck and threw himself off
the cliff and got up and jabbed and had
the conversation between two two guys
Jim Carrey set the tone for other people
to do it and get hard what I'm trying to
do the prison yard scene and I'm
imitating two people that's a reflection
of Jim Carrey and what Jim County has
shown when you go look at Ace Ventura
pet detective and from the silliness of
Jim Carrey talking with his but that's
that stuff now human look if you look at
him you think comedy man that stuff
sticks in people's heads Jim Carrey uh
acting like he was birth out the
elephants bud and playing like the baby
stuff he is a different level of
thinking and he just went dark for a
minute and went into serious roles but I
don't think anybody touches Jim Carrey
in that realm and you know from what I
do and what I attempt to do I'm
attempting things and creating nuances
from the things that I've seen from the
greats and Jim Carrey is one of those
greats shot at the Rob Williams I can't
do impressions but if I could I would
definitely try to do them the way you
did it brother cuz nobody does a better
rusted piece I'm beyond confident I'm
not cocky I'm so confident I'm confident
on Who I am I'm confident in the person
that I am I think I'm sexy I tell my
lady all-time babe I'm sexy I've got two
ugly totems that's it that's the only
thing I just I love me and and you sexy
with your socks on yeah means I don't
take my socks off okay I'll take my but
I'll wear good socks that's the plus I
just don't believe I don't believe in
change I don't believe in in doing
things to to manufacture my body to
appeal to what I think people might like
this is is it this is this is what I was
given there's my playing cards if we
just playing poker I got to make this
hand work yeah this is it for me and
this is what I'm gonna ride out so how
do you not embrace it you won like yeah
one in one life I'm gonna embrace my you
run out of energy emotionally physically
not sleeping this is me oh this is me on
no sleep right now um I don't I keep I
can't express how happy of a person I am
I can't express how inspiring in ah I
guess you can say motivating my life and
the people around me are I think there's
a fine line you don't ever want to
offend people you don't ever want to
stir up any trouble sardines ative you
keep itself evolved you're fine you know
the key in the art that I've learned is
basically to do these things with the
doing in such a cool way people laugh
but they go yo even though he's saying
things that he's saying
the way he's saying it it's funny the
way he's saying the way he goes about it
to get his point across it's very unique
and funny and that's the trick to being
universal and making everybody laugh
what can you pass along to your kids
that they would understand uh what you
know what George is funny you say that
because uh Ivan I'm having a hard time
with figuring out the type of life
lessons you know that I've done trying
to hand my kids you know basically as a
father you want to teach your kid
certain things I look back at my life
George you know however not to teach
here's the one thing like okay my
daughter and this is me being very
honest you guys my daughter's a little
princess beautiful she's spoiled so you
know I'm one way with her boom my son
I'm like I live in LA I'm in the valley
you know my son ain't around tough kids
my main thing is teaching my son how to
fight and how old is he my son's three
okay you know this thing goes all these
daycares crazy all right
I caught a little boy putting paste in
my son's mouth that's what I had enough
time to teach my son how to defend
himself now the only problem I'm having
my son my son thinks he's spider-man
George for real like this
I'm not joking like like when we play he
went me like this
but because I'm dead like because I'm
his dad when he does it I gotta act like
I'm cold I'm like oh no you know let me
out let me out so lets us play it let me
tell you why this is bad I'm not joking
so I go to pick him up from school right
this little boys hitting my son in the
head with a truck right my son on the
floor doing this
no I'm not so laughing boy you make your
chance you're not spider-man
you're not spider moves you try to get
me okay let me out let dad out y'all
lads I'm being so serious man for my
household son is in trouble if I don't
save him hey you really think he's
fighting me joy oh don't judge my son
don't come here web sort of web oh yeah
yeah
y'all better act like y'all coordinate
Kevin I want you to pretend that you're
Dwayne in high school and and Riley
you're you're Kevin in high school okay
and answer just a few questions I'm
Kevin Hart high school right now 17
years old okay DJ hey you guys go what
would you like to be when you grow up
okay
I'm packing me a fireman that would be
cool
hey I'm willing to be a fireman are you
gonna eat that pudding okay right even
come back with something strong yeah
okay
I'm Kevin Hart right right high school
okay you sure hear me cheering Oh
panting come on come on hey miss Johnson
yeah I'm gonna do good on that test yes
sorry I think it's two flies having sex
behind you look at this very serious
look how big that is that's two flies
you see that Wow
I'm sorry I was pretty amazing to me
never see anything oh oh Jesus Christ
all right and the little guy was a
strategy to fighting first of all uh I
don't want people fight man you know I'm
a god of most positive so I love love
but if you are gonna fight and you small
you bite your bite well you're gonna
bite man to go go low and bite go go for
go for either cash or an Achilles tendon
that's what you might
everybody knows that it'll take your
opponent out nobody can't withstand a
bike on Achilles tendon you're gonna do
this instantly that person goes down and
get the best of him you want everybody
knows did you have that girl's like did
you have a lot of trouble keeping a
short guy and try to my work yeah
now upbeat a woman knows I'm a known
killer man
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because Samari Alexander
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I also love to
know which of the top 10 rule to the
biggest impact on you and why what
change you're going to make now after
watching this video leave in the
comments I'll join the discussion thank
you so much for watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon
now there is a beautiful crowd man I
love big crowds just to get something
off my chest before I even start
everything I say here tonight is a joke
okay
it was nothing else I don't know how to
mentally stuff to series I mean nobody
come up to me after the show talking
about who's the funny one now
don't let it be known try to fight I
would rob a lot of times in life
don't get your stuff you know that point
now we'll drink oh I just get real fan
right here don't make no sudden
movements and put your hands on
we'll be different about getting Bravo
big people you know think that [ __ ] be
robbing people you know are you a big
guy you brought me a fake setter you
know why you're bigger 14 I would let it
go there's not going down like that
you're not gonna get robbed by women so
kids run up or down
you know you go skiing you call initial
mister
he brought me he upset with me because I
didn't know
yeah
talking to you you wait a minute all
right
look at him
Oh
get robbed you know they say it made you
together right so I run upon us to rock
us if I run from the situation I'm a
[ __ ] through this business situation
right head around certain friends of
mine
until my girl an Iowa
No
me because she goes you know I'm
stealing just watching that was the king
is my time I got away I'm not she had
keys to the car turn around they were
still hitting us go something I'm
waiting
ain't no sense in both of us getting I
have
that would be somebody
somebody had to get us home that's all I
had to say no female judges don't
realize men people are too crazy to be
fighting everybody man people are losing
their minds now to be fighting everybody
I'm sorry I'm not a hostile person I'm
friendly and out a minute I don't like
to fight
I'm a friend your friend take nothing
out on me you know where I was I saw
something crazy my senior while I was on
a train I swear my life for the whole
people really get me mad because they
get upset with you where you don't want
to give up yet see you no no the hell
with you I'm tired too
do not do like you sleep
is she coming back she came back
I'll give up your seat no there's no one
left I like that her Borgata stands like
this in a center and then when a bus get
real crowded or something that's when
you gotta ground in there but excuse me
babe I'm just trying to get my head hey
right there
I'm not mobile here baby no boo I can't
believe they set you up front
oh good he is a professional grinder you
can't have that for living man you know
they're not gonna be this crazy me
myself I think dirty people might be
some of the craziest people out there
too because you have to be some kind of
crazy a mental person just decide at
some point of your life to be dirty you
know that's a crazy decision you know
how does something like that go down
would you just wake up one morning man I
ain't watching I ask no more and then go
back to sleep
you can't keep saying look at the watch
me
let's go for the first couple days but
do be saying the same thing
everybody wants a tattoo now you know
everybody needs a tattoo I have no
problem with tattoos I feel then you're
gonna get a tattoo get something that
you know what it says everybody want a
Chinese tattoo now so what it really
says you walk you home Oh
careful
yeah see those people in the gym that
are too strong yes he's by the gym
that's too strong got too many muscles
you know I saw this one guy up here too
many months like a total that's enough
damn don't you left nothing out where
you gonna put that muscle and he told us
some nah get this sauce spot behind my
hair do me a favor put 345 pounds on the
back of my neck so I can go ahead and
lift that up and I want to go get it I
looked at him in her face that was the
[ __ ] to have rocne hey y'all be the
great common name is Kevin right